[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
it was a show uh called now or neverland
and they did it in holland and then um a
company called endemol bought it
brought it to america and they just
changed the name to fear factor did you
ever help with any of like the fantastic
people no no no no no
98 of the time during that show i was
high as [__]
that's that's how i got through it i
would i'd take uh pot lollipops with me
to work yeah
and i just suck on the lollipop until it
felt just right
then i could enjoy the show because
watching that [__] was [__] it was
just it was just such a weird job
because i thought when i signed up to do
it i really thought it was going to be
canceled i was like how are they going
to stick dogs on people how are they
going to make people and eat eyeballs
and [__] this is going to go off another
contest remember the movie um what was
that movie about death what was the
movie
which movie
the movie of the
documentary of death the faces of death
yeah
when they eat in the monkey yeah
was that real some of them were fake
though right but the monkey thing is
very real
some of them are fake i think monkey
brings actually like a delicacy yeah in
some cultures people need to get their
[__] together
go have an apple
[__] you eating a mushroom
how do you prepare for your first time
though because i'm nervous
i've heard you got to do a dieta which
is a 10 day fast where you go
only
stop all that hippie [__]
put your [__] wooden beads aside but
this is got
it's the same thing it's
dimethyltryptamine look it's good to
have an empty stomach yeah yeah but
listen what you really need to do is
just relax and let it happen have you
taken ayah no i've only taken dmv we've
got to do iowa
a debate that needs to be settled oh
because the last time we all hung out
mark was with us after the fight you
remember we went to the fight in phoenix
in phoenix and um and we sat down at a
great steak restaurant i think we're
giving a [__] for this first off and um
enjoy a fish or something
okay we're sitting down you get the
tomahawk
yes okay
everybody else looks at the menu and
they look at the most expensive thing
and they go i'll just do one below that
out of respect for joe who's going to
pay for this dinner as you always do
what are you doing
it's sitting like this it goes it goes
joe and then mark and then joe goes oh
the tomahawk and then mark doesn't even
wait for the waiter to come over he goes
double it up
it's a good move yeah okay i don't i
don't see where where there's a problem
thank you
it's so it's an
expensive steak oh you don't think joe
can do that you don't think joe's got it
we're having fun come on bro yeah you
can't think like that
you can't think like that
you cannot think like that and you've
been hanging out with me too long yeah i
think that's uh yeah you sounded super
nasally right there i think you're doing
it up for john
you should never think like that okay
it's just a restaurant it's not you're
not buying ferraris
yeah you know
but we call it steaks
you go buying steaks for people who
gives a [__] you supposed to drink have
fun order wine
have a good time yeah now mark was a
little disappointed that you didn't
finish your steak bro okay all right i
didn't say like that i didn't no you
didn't say it like that you didn't
and you were like
i finished it and i thought about
finishing his i didn't know it was you
i thought we were just having fun yeah i
left a couple of pieces of meat
you did bring it up you were like man
you know i could do two of these easy
and i was like all right well if you're
going for it i'm gonna go for it and
then i did not say i could do two come
on come on bro
you [__] people are the weirdest
things you focus on
you people you people you guys
people human beings
[Music]
when he gets on the first thing he's
going to talk about is how much she ate
a month ago
you changed this into like a regular
studio
you've abandoned all the rules of
podcasts that's right we have what are
the rules of podcasts there's no rules
there's no rule yeah yeah it's a great
studio
we ordered all kinds of food that didn't
get eaten there was desserts and all
kinds of [__] was flowing around that
table and lobsters and no i'd be pissed
if i paid for somebody's food and they
didn't eat it well you got to let that
go [__]
there's even more benefits to drinking
semen for women because it's very
antidepressant because it contains
melatonin oh it can i can just take it i
don't know
just get that from vitamins all right
oh i just got the chills for real oh
jesus
she's showing it to you she's dripping
surprisingly no it's not surprising well
let's see if everybody's uh
the guy who's what they're writing i
produced some of my own semen videos
watching this
give me a call if you ever need some
straight from the source
[Laughter]
i hope you at least give the donor a
hand job you selfish [__]
[Laughter]
i have lots of scene when i can unload
on those big breasts
jesus why not disable the comments for
this video like she said keep him
rocking would you date her knowing she's
drunk she's drank so many gum shots yeah
of course yeah who cares i used to have
a whole bit about that yeah now about uh
i dated a girl once and she told me that
when guys drink uh fruit juice
especially pineapple juice oh yeah it
makes your [__] taste better and i was
like how many dicks do you have to suck
before you figure that out yeah like
that's
it's not what's not too asparagus
not good okay let's try roast beef
my dad bought me a pool table when i was
like maybe
12 13 i mean he used to run it all the
time yeah i think that's pretty cool
that that that's used to be your thing
you ever hear the singer emma james
emma james yeah yeah i've heard the name
she said minnesota fest was her father
oh wow
probably he probably got around that was
back in the day you'd get laid if you
played good pool that's hilarious
you know what's your strategy mike how
you gonna get laid i'm gonna learn how
to play pool real good
most people avoid them at all costs but
if you [__] up and you're too close to a
moose they'll come for you they're
different they're different than any
other wild animal because they deal with
wolves so they're like real good at
stomping
feel good
that's what they have to do if you want
to stay alive
so in a parking lot in anchorage alaska
yeah you might get stomped to death yeah
that's real that's how will smith bro
it's not a little slap that's a stomach
they're 1800 pounds when they're the
giant bulls yeah i might have made that
up
[Laughter]
i mean there's a mass amount of attack
on you
outside of being a public persona
outside of being a
comedian podcaster you're you're also a
human being so how did you survive that
how did you sort of uh
walk through that fire because you
seemed to do with grace
i used mushrooms
[Laughter]
that was one way i did it yeah yeah
really i should have never smoked that
[__] i liked it
all right be honest but one to ten damn
one to ten light it up again joe [__] it
let's go we're going for it we're going
for it
i like how you went leather i always
wear this one it's my nice one yeah
i love that you wear
[Music]
andrew has one of those but he wears
around his shoulder which i think is way
gayer oh yeah that's well it's just a
cop out yeah thank you you're just
afraid you gave it to me i'm afraid
you're afraid of this look
it's just two balls look at this
it's like a kilt it's like what it looks
like when a man does not give a [__]
look at this
this is what it's supposed to look like
this is what you've been working for
this is better it's better i can keep
stuff in there it's better
it's just better yeah what about pockets
yeah but they get in the way they're
digging your legs
[Laughter]
is that the dumbest [__] story of all
time with the beds yeah they found out
she was a princess because they put a p
like 13. yeah
she couldn't sleep
[Laughter]
imagine like she's a princess because
her body is so weak
that if you put a
but imagine that that's supposed to be a
good trait yeah but that's how you can
tell she's a princess she can't even
sleep with a pee under there yeah she's
so delicate delicate that a pe [__]
her up yeah and that's supposed to be
amazing
like what are you talking about that's
like the more fat and pale you were back
in the day like the more high society
you are yeah food man if you could
afford gluttony in the face of abject
poverty all around you yeah people are
literally starving to death
and you're a slob and you're sleeping on
food
just filled gut with wine yeah
that was the first gordon gekko that was
it that was just a guy that was super
fat in the 1700s greed is good
everybody's everybody's like we could
just get a few crumbs
no i'm gonna go
[Laughter]
hey guys thanks for watching this video
so far we have a really quick message
from our newest sponsor the freeze pipe
but be sure to keep watching afterwards
for some more great joe rogan guest
moments
all right so if you've been in this
space for a while you probably already
know what this is if not this is called
a freeze bomber right it's from a
company called freeze pipe now everyone
knows the most common way to cool your
hits is to actually just put ice cubes
in whatever piece you have basically
freeze pipe just said let's make that
into a simplified version less of a
hassle more convenient and more
efficient and that's basically what we
have here today this little intricate
piece right here in front of me
all right guys so as you can see there
is a glycerin chamber you can see the
glycerin making its little bubbles up
what the glycerin does it's going to
cool your hit so the smoke is
transferred from the pipe through the
little coils
down until here where you get to hit it
grease pipe of course has freezable
pipes uh freezable rigs they got bulbous
they got different size bongs anything
that gets smoked out of they have it on
the website oh my gosh this thing's so
badass when you hit it you literally
feel the smoke getting cooled into your
lungs so it provides a super nice hit
that was awesome
pipe with glycerin inside of it freeze
it for an hour ice cold hits honestly
that was cold and smooth as [__] i
seriously think this is the only rig
i've ever taken a dab out of and never
coughed where's the freeze pipe bring me
that damn freeze pipe i'm sick and the
only cure is to bring me my freeze pipe
it's almost impossible for us with our
human wart reward systems that are based
on like animal emotions and biology to
man to manage
millions and millions and millions of
people all on one continent with money
and the economy and the [__]
environment it's almost impossible to do
so it almost always slides into
authoritarianism and the best way it
slides into authoritarianism is to
control the narrative
you got to leave keep going brother
so you say it's almost impossible how
would you say we can do it mushrooms
beautifully
let me ask are you really googling am i
mean how dare you
who's doing that
how are you doing and sticking that in
front of my face
how to not make someone feel comfortable
who's got a giant screen is joe rogan
mean you feel that [__] right here
that should probably do your can you get
me the north korean
oh my god well she has a name oh my gosh
you're gonna make me pronounce the name
bro
she's the north korean i think there's
another truck yeah i was talking about
kim oh you're somebody
no is there do you think that she would
ever come on
you could reach out young me young me
parker yummy parker
story is crazy yeah
what else is so crazy
we're just trying to talk about that
we send each other memes he'll send me
pictures of a dude squatting
and i know exactly what he's talking
about
the heavies
the soup heavies bro now she got
something bro
that's how they make them out there that
was okay the majority of our interaction
on text messages for a solid four or
five days
[Laughter]
andrew just texted me the heavies
dying
listen your boy getting a little saucy
and it is what it is you know
asher's a guard
what
what do you think about circumcising
women
why i might have made a mistake ladies
and gentlemen
full responsibility for whatever happens
here
it's clearly my fault why'd you get them
high because i wanted to see
i gotta experience it bro i was watching
uh anthony robbins instagram stories
uh-huh tony robbins is in uh he's in
australia and he gets out to that uh
with what's that um black ip song
tonight's gonna be a good night and he's
out there yes and he's clapping with his
big [__] frankenstein hands yeah
fire and he's like stomping around on
stage yeah but it's all like
it's it's like he's his energy is kind
of forced yes and he's got yes he's a
little too wide around the waist which
means eating a little too good
living it up a little too much and so
yes we're all excited we're going to
prosper here
everybody say aye
that one makes me crazy and it says
in one of the photos i saved the photo
because i was laughing so hard
i saved it on my phone because it said
savage there's a picture of him and he's
dancing around clapping and it just says
savage i'm like settle the [__] down
buddy by the way that life coach thing
look let me see
savage
that's what his instagram story is why
is that savage
it's hit with his hands in his pocket
but this all is dad bod relax
some
i like tony robbins a lot but the fake
energy thing i if i went to his seminar
and he made me [__] stand up and do
jumping jacks every five minutes i blow
my brains out i don't like that stuff
[Music]
facial features so he has like a very
mild form of it i think so yeah
something he has a giant hog probably
yeah that's part of what his confidence
is right for sure
every time and every time he's probably
meeting with his team there's enough
push back on somebody goes let me show
you something it's a fat roller carpet
he's like look at that thing slaps that
thing down and the interns like he's got
a point
rolled up pizza dough oh yeah
just real quick here at the end i know
that joe's been on the tim dillon show
and this past weekend with theo van and
there's another lex episode that he did
but those episodes all took place in joe
rogan's studio so it kind of didn't seem
like he was a guest it seemed like he
was interviewing those other people and
it didn't really fit the vibe for this
video but if you'd like to see those
episodes in part two because technically
he was the guest let me know in the
comments thank you for watching and
please subscribe to joke world turn on
the post notifications and check us out
on spotify to support the show after
putting your gear on
this is this is the future this is this
is gonna be really weird man it's gonna
be really really really really strange
ah well
joe
thank you so much man this is we're done
that's we gotta go we got a show to do
right 7 19. also i didn't get a chance
to show you the vr porn yet which you've
got oh my goodness you have to glimpse
[Music]
you